as you might expect Android stores your
persistent data in the file system to
simplify what app developers need to
write Android provides several
structured storage options on top of the
file system for sunshine will leverage
both shared preferences and an SQLite
database let's look at both of these
options the shared preferences class
which we are already using to store user
ZIP code in units provides a general
framework that allows you to save and
retrieve persistent key value pairs of
primitive data types such as boolean x'
floats
intz Long's and strings there are times
when a simple key value pair framework
like shared preferences doesn't provide
enough flexibility
fortunately Android also has SQLite
SQLite implements a lightweight
relational database we interact with
SQLite databases by writing queries and
statements and SQLite variant of the
structured query language or SQL storing
something in a database is more
complicated than using shared
preferences so why would we ever choose
this option after all Android supports
both raw files and shared preferences as
alternatives well for the same reason
that it's inefficient to find things if
you throw your clothes at a pile on the
floor storing things in an SQLite
database helps you organize and find
data easily thanks to the power of
indexing and tables let's see what this
looks like here is an SQLite database
table from our weather database no not
all fields are represented all of the
data for the first days in the first row
the data for the second days in the
second row and so on with key value
pairs it would be difficult to associate
a row of data this way as you continue
through this section on database storage
and Android we're going to expect some
basic understanding of SQLite in
relational databases including what a
create select update delete and insert
operation is will help you write these
operations but if you are new to SQLite
or need a refresher head over to the
tutorial linked in the instructor
notes below once we have a database up
and running on our device for our app
getting the information we need using
SQL is easy we can perform queries
against this database such as this
select statement here which returns the
weather on the specified date similar to
what we will want to do for the detail
view we can use a slightly more complex
query to return a range of dates which
is similar to what we do on the main
forecast list view once again if any of
this was unfamiliar please consider
working through the SQL I tutorial
linked in the instructor notes and even
if it isn't unfamiliar you might just
learn something ok here's a slightly
more complicated SQL query see the
instructor notes for some resources that
you can use to help parse the SQL
statement one note max is the name of
the column that stores the high
temperature for the day